It's time to tuck yourself away with
a perfectly splendid new story in
the Haunting series featuring spooky
new ghosts and murderous matriarchs.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and
in this video we're diving beneath the
surface of Bly Manor to explain everything
about the ending, the Lady of the Lake,
the haunted house and its ghosts,
plus what the final scene really means.
Obviously spoilers ahead, so take care.
Bly Manor's original matriarch, Viola, aka the
Lady of the Lake, is at the heart of this story
and the eighth episode is crucial for
understanding the origins
of this season's mysteries.
Viola was a confident woman who,
contrary to the norms of the time,
took charge of her own affairs and refused
to bow to either her husband or the Church.
While her marriage was more of a business
arrangement, she loved her daughter dearly,
clinging to her tightly as they
slept together each night.
And true to her possessive nature, she warned her
child about those who might seek control over the
manor in the future:
"It is you.
It is me.
It is us."
That moment is the origin of the phrase
that gives ghosts like Peter Quint the
permission they need to possess a living
person such as Rebecca Jessel or Miles.
"It's you.
It's me.
It's us."
We also see Viola's jealously and controlling
traits in her relationship with her sister.
When she first notices a look between Perdita
and her husband, the beginnings of
a deadly lung disease manifest.
Later on, she becomes violently jealous of
Perdita after she finds her dancing with Arthur,
and it's no coincidence that Peter Quint acts in
a similar way in his relationship with Rebecca.
The Lady of the Lake's stranglehold over Bly
Manor is only broken in the final episode when,
desperate to save Flora from a watery
doom, Dani offers Viola permission to
live in her body.
"It's you!
It's me!
It's us!"
We don't know exactly why Viola agrees,
but it could be that Dani's body offered
her the opportunity to escape
her endless cycle of purgatory,
or perhaps what Dani said jolted some
faded memory of the words she'd said
previously to her own daughter.
Either way, it seems that Dani's
will is superior enough at that moment to keep
the Lady of the Lake repressed for a while.
The moment also breaks Viola's
spell over all of the other
ghosts trapped at Bly, who now disappear.
And as Viola accepts Dani's invitation, the colour
of this eye here changes from blue to brown.
Before this moment, both Dani's eyes were blue;
but from this point on, she
has one blue and one brown eye,
a mark of the beast now living in her body.
Another detail that represents how Dani isn't
entirely human any longer is the doll that
Flora gives to her when they say goodbye.
"Are you sure you wanna give me this one?"
"You must have it.
It's you."
Flora regarding Dani
as a doll in some way means deep down the little
girl senses something has changed in the au pair,
because it contrasts sharply with what she said
to Dani when she first arrived at Bly Manor.
"Is that me?"
"Why, no, silly.
You're you.
It's just a dolly."
Dani fears the spirit of Viola inside her
and explains to Jamie that it isn't peaceful,
but is filled with rage.
"She's waiting.
And at some point...
she's gonna take me."
The final episode's title "The Beast in
the Jungle" comes from the novella of
the same name by Henry James in which
a man is seized by the fear that some
unknown catastrophe lies in wait for him.
For Dani, she understandably fears the beast
inside her;
however,
unlike the book's protagonist, Dani and Jamie vow
to make the most of whatever time they have left,
travelling then setting up a life together.
"One day at a time is what we've got.
It's what everybody's got
when you get down to it."
And, similar to Viola, Dani discovers she
has a lot longer than she first thought
and she's able to live relatively
peacefully for over five years.
By this time though, Dani feels that the beast
is drowning out her own feelings more and more,
and one night when she wakes up to
discover she's about to choke Jamie,
she understands the time has come when
it's too dangerous to stay another day.
When Jamie discovers Dani has drowned
herself in the lake at Bly Manor,
she begs her to take her as well,
but unlike Viola's vengeful spirit,
Dani's soul refuses because, in contrast
to the previous Lady of the Lake,
Dani's actions are motivated by selfless love.
Jamie goes through life looking at reflections
in the hope that Dani might come back to her.
When the older Jamie played by Carla Gugino, goes
back to her hotel room after the wedding, there's
a hint towards a happy-ish ending of sorts.
She runs a bath and fills a sink with water,
leaves her room door ajar, then falls asleep.
As the camera cuts to behind Jamie we see what
looks likes Dani's hand on Jamie's shoulder,
the clues being the ring on her
finger and the sweater sleeve.
My interpretation of this shot is
that Dani isn't literally in the room,
but rather as Jamie fell asleep they were
both reunited in her dream or memory,
while Dani's spirit or
ghost remains at Bly Manor.
The clue to this is what the storyteller says to
the wedding party about Dani's ultimate fate.
"She will merely walk the grounds of Bly,
harmless as a dove, for all of her days.
Leaving the only trace of who she once was in
the memory of the woman who loved her most."
In the show, we see that even living
characters like Flora can experience
an old memory in a dream world of sorts,
and I think that perhaps Jamie is tucked away
in a memory with Dani in this final moment.
If you like this theory about the ending,
then leave a thumbs-up and let me know
what you think in the comments below.
Another cool detail about this final scene is
that it cleverly links back to the opening scene
of the very first episode where the storyteller
Jamie wakes up from her sleep at the hotel,
which suggests that she has been repeating
this routine for several nights with
the hope of reuniting with Dani.
And the way the end of the season in
effect loops back to the beginning makes me
think of the idea from Hill House that time
isn't always linear but can fold in on itself.
"I thought for so long that time was like a line.
But I was wrong.
It's not like that at all.
Our moments fall around us like rain."
Viola is also the origin of the strange time
loops that many of Bly's ghosts
find themselves trapped in.
Despite her prognosis by a doctor that she would
only have months left to live, her will to cling
to life is stronger and she remains alive a
full six years after she initially falls later.
"I do not go."
Sick of her sister, Perdita decides to kill her;
however, even then Viola's will keeps her
spirit trapped in the realm of Bly Manor,
locked away in the trunk of her clothes and
jewels that she had put away for her daughter.
Here, in this self-made purgatory, Viola
lives the same day over and over, sleeping,
waking and waiting for someone
with the key to open the trunk.
"And she admitted her room was a
dream, a construct, a lie preferred...
to the truth of the trunk."
Although Viola's endless cycle
is broken when Perdita opens the trunk, affording
Viola an opportunity for revenge on her sister,
sadness consumes her when she feels abandoned
by her husband and daughter after they sell
the house and toss the trunk into the lake.
But Viola's will still holds her to this world
and she begins a new unending cycle of sleeping,
waking and this time walking from her watery new
home to her daughter's bedroom and back again.
Her power, even as a ghost, is the reason why
everyone who dies on the manor grounds
is unable to leave and they end up as
ghosts stuck in a limbo similar to hers.
"The pull of that next world ignored, she instead
made her own gravity, gravity of will, that
would change the terrain of Bly Manor forever."
And it could be said that her power even
extends a little to the nearby town of Bly,
something alluded to in the first episode:
"The people here, most of them,
they're born here, they die here.
The whole town is one big gravity well."
Similar to Viola, each of the other ghosts
at Bly find themselves living in a loop
of their own construction after they die.
They're able to hop around between memories,
but they always seem to end up returning
to some defining moment in their life.
For Peter Quint, he always finds himself
returning to a moment which he describes as Hell,
because he has to repeatedly see his
mother come to try and blackmail him,
the same person who enabled his father's
abuse of him and other children.
"It's like I'm in hell."
"Well, where else would you go?"
Miss Jessel finds herself returning to
a moment where Peter photographs her
over and over while she's wearing
Charlotte Wingrave's fur coat.
"Not this one, please."
"Let me show you how beautiful you are."
Rebecca hates this memory, because
it's the time when she decided to go
along with Peter's lies against her better
judgement and despite Mrs Grose's warnings.
This seminal moment ultimately led to
Peter completely deceiving her when he
takes possession of her body and drowns
her so that she ends up stuck with him.
In Mrs Grose's case, she finds herself returning
to the moment when she first met Owen.
Her loop is not as unpleasant as Peter's or
Rebecca's, perhaps because she doesn't suffer
the same regret or guilt that Rebecca or Peter
do for their actions when they were alive.
Her loop can be disconcerting for
her at times though, because she's
not aware to begin with that she's dead,
but she's essentially spending time with
the person who she grows to love
and who becomes her soulmate.
A theme that becomes clear by the end of Bly Manor
is that the story we've seen isn't just a ghost
story, but also a love story.
"Same thing, really."
As creator Mike Flanagan told Vanity Fair, the
show "provides a new way to tell a love story"
and "by the end [of the season], it's really
hard to differentiate tragedy [from] romance.
That sense of romantic longing for someone who
meant so much to us – but who's gone – really
is the heart of any ghost story."
And as we see over the season,
Bly Manor includes many types of love,
from healthy relationships to toxic
and guilt-ridden romances, each with their own
power to either exorcise or create new ghosts.
When Dani and Jamie finally recognise their
true feelings for each other, this moment
exorcises the ghost of her dead fiancé Edmund
which has been haunting her since he died.
The day after Jamie and Dani sleep
together, Dani is finally able to
look in a mirror without seeing his
ghost staring back accusingly at her.
Dani's true love for Jamie helps her
let go of her guilt over his death.
As Mike Flanagan has said, in the
Haunting anthology series ghosts
are "an expression of emotional wounds"
and through her relationship with Jamie,
Dani is finally able to heal
her trauma from Edmund's death.
Likewise, it's Dani's selfless love for
Flora and willingness to sacrifice her own
life when she invites Viola to possess
her which exorcises all of the ghosts
that have been trapped at Bly Manor.
In contrast to Dani and Jamie,
Peter Quint and Rebecca Jessel's relationship
is particularly toxic and filled with jealousy,
deceit, and manipulation.
One of the manifestations of
this is how the pair take possession of Miles
and Flora often without their permission,
something we see through the children's
strange behaviours such as Miles demanding
to be given wine, and smoking and talking
in a manner untypical for a boy of his age.
Peter is the principal toxic
force in the relationship
and we see him abuse the trust
Rebecca places in him when she
gives him permission to take control of her
body so that they can be together forever.
Her stipulation was that they be equals,
however, without asking for her consent,
he selfishly drowns her in the lake, trapping
her as a ghost with him forever at Bly Manor.
A little detail foreshadowing just how bad
Peter Quint will end up being for Miss Jessel
is when the song "Tainted Love" plays
in episode 3 just before he and Henry
interview Rebecca for the au pair job.
And bound up with this idea of toxic love
is the theme of possession and ownership.
The two most destructive ghosts at Bly Manor,
Peter Quint and Viola, are obsessed with
trying to control the people around them.
In fact, in many ways, Peter doesn't treat
Rebecca like an autonomous human being with wants,
needs, and rights of her own;
rather, he treats her like property;
he sees what he wants and takes it without
permission, whether that's draining Henry
Wingrave's bank accounts, stealing
jewellery and fur coats from Bly Manor,
or taking Rebecca's life forever.
And the way Peter manipulates people
to do exactly what he wants is like a child
playing with a toy, or like Flora playing with
her dolls, as Mike Flanagan says.
As we know from Peter's hell loop,
he was similarly dehumanised as a child.
However, as Dani explains, treating people
like this is the antithesis of true love.
"People do, don't they?
Mix up love and possession.
I don't think that should be possible.
I mean, they're opposites, really.
Love and ownership."
When grown-up Flora tells the storyteller that
she's scared of losing her forever person,
Jamie replies that they should enjoy their
time together and not worry about that,
and when that moment comes, she can still
enjoy the memories of their time together,
and, as I said earlier, that's
something we see Jamie do herself
at the very end of the season.
It's also something the older
Owen talked about in his speech at the
rehearsal dinner in the first episode.
"To truly love another person is to
accept that the work of loving them
is worth the pain of losing them."
Mrs Grose proves this point at the end, when
she selflessly decides to leave the memory she's
in with Owen to help him in the real world.
"Be brave in death, Hannah.
We both know you're not so selfish...
to remain hidden in a memory."
Likewise, Dani's Lady in the
Lake refuses to drag Jamie down with her.
And, similarly, in the end, Rebecca manages to
reject Peter's manipulations and helps protect
Flora by refusing to possess her as well.
The other main love story at Bly
Manor is between Henry and Charlotte,
the wife of his brother Dominic.
After Dominic discovers what's been
going on, he and Charlotte go on a trip
to India to repair their marriage where
they're tragically killed in an accident.
The tremendous guilt that Henry suffered
when he heard the news and the knowledge that
he was indirectly responsible for their deaths
gave birth to his doppelganger ghost that night.
And this ties in with what Mike Flanagan has
said that "when we fall in love,
we give birth to a new ghost."
Henry's antagonistic alter ego ghost was the
product of the guilt and sadness he felt upon
learning of the death of the woman he loved.
And similar to the ghosts at Bly Manor,
Henry seems to live much of his life in
a loop, even though he's still alive.
His brother might have forbidden him
from returning to Bly after his affair,
but Henry's overbearing sense of guilt
means he doesn't even leave his office
at night to go to his home in London.
He also feels compelled to repeatedly
call Bly Manor, making him the cause
of the silent calls at the house.
Coming up are a couple more videos
on Bly Manor including all the secret
hidden ghosts lurking in the house
plus another video with easter eggs
and more spooky details you might
have missed in the episodes.
Tap here for my Haunting of Bly Manor playlist
or follow the link in the video description.
So, what did you think of The
Haunting of Bly Manor and its ending?
And do you have any theories about Dani, or
any of the ghosts or characters in the story?
Leave your thoughts and
ideas in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this, then a
thumbs-up is hugely appreciated!
Tap left to watch my next Bly Manor video or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!